Die Bilder von der Absturzstelle im mexikanischen
Bundesstaat Durango lassen Schlimmes vermuten.
Doch die Passagiere an Bord der Maschine der
Fluggesellschaft Aeormexiko haben offenbar
Glück im Unglück gehabt.
Bei dem Flugzeugabsturz am Dienstag wurden
zwar mindestens 85 Menschen verletzt, es hat
aber wohl keine Todesopfer gegeben.
Das Flugzeug habe etwa zehn Kilometer vom
Flughafen in Durango entfernt eine Notlandung
gemacht, sagte ein Sprecher des örtlichen
Zivilschutzes im Fernsehen.
Augenzeugen hätten von einem lauten Knall
berichtet, bevor die Maschine zu Boden ging,
sagte der Gouverneur der Provinz.
An Bord der Maschine befanden sich den Angaben
zufolge mehr als 100 Menschen.
Der Flughafenbetreiber führte das Unglück
auf schlechtes Wetter zurück.
Kurz nach dem Start sei die Maschine von einer
Windböe erfasst worden, hieß es.
Die Verletzten wurden zur Behandlung ins Krankenhaus
gebracht.
Einige von ihnen befinden sich in einem kritischen
Zustand, sagt der Arzt Sergio Gonzalez:
"Sie werden noch untersucht, 25 von denjenigen,
die wir hier haben, haben keine ernsten Verletzungen.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es zehn Personen,
deren Zustand ernst ist.
Einer von ihnen muss operiert werden."
Auch der Pilot habe Verbrennungen erlitten
und befinde sich in einem ernsten Zustand
hieß es.
Alle Passagiere samt Crew hätten sich aber
retten können, ehe das Flugzeug Feuer gefangen
habe.